der long train tempel in den bergen nur
60 kilometer entfernt von der
chinesischen hauptstadt
bis vor gut zehn jahren war er verfallen
und verlassen
denn bis anfang der siebziger jahre
wurden die mönche in china verfolgt von
dem tempel standen nur noch die
grundmauern
seit 2005 wird er wieder aufgebaut und
strahlt heute kraft und ruhe aus wie vor
über 1000 jahren
auch die mönche sind wieder da derzeit
bereits über 150 die ihre alten
schriften studieren in der hoffnung den
buddhismus in china wieder zum leben zu
erwecken
manche auf durchaus eigene weise kann
fahren zum beispiel er hat kunst in
peking studiert bevor er hierher kam
und das brachte ihn auf eine idee er
erfand eine neue figuren einem
zeichentrick mönch mittlerweile
markenzeichen für den tempel
ich habe ihn extra quadratisch gemacht
weil das im moment sehr gut ankommt so
mische ich die alte mal tradition mit
dem was draußen gerade beliebt ist das
gezeichnete maskottchen ist mittlerweile
ein riesenerfolg und sein erfinder sun
fun herrscher über ein ganzes karton
imperium im herzen des klosters und
studenten aus peking reißen sich darum
hier als volontäre zu helfen die
abenteuer des kleinen john a in comics
umzusetzen
der größte hit ist derzeit aber die
allerneuste wiedergeburt des gelben
mönchs als roboter
hier rät er gerade ruhe zu bewahren und
somit ist seinen vorgänger scheint er
damit nicht zu stören
wie ist das wetter heute kannst du nicht
selbst aus dem fenster gucken warum bist
du so dick die frage beantworte ich
nicht was isst am liebsten roboter es
nicht das ist eine blöde frage
manchmal wird das sauer wenn man ihm zu
viele unsinnige frage stellt und dann
verweigert er sich aber grundsätzlich
funktionierte wirklich gut so gut dass
das land kloster an wochenenden oft
regelrecht überlaufen wird
manche sind touristen und kommen
tatsächlich nur wegen kanal aber viele
menschen suchen nach mehr die suche nach
ruhe und entspannung
im heutigen china ist die wirtschaft so
atemberaubend schnell gewachsen dass es
den menschen zwar materiell sehr viel
besser geht sie aber jetzt spüren dass
das auch angst und druck erzeugt
im moment sind es jedes wochenende an
die 1000 leyen die hierher kommen um
gemeinsam mit den mönchen zu meditieren
und mantras zu singen
direkt gegenüber des alten klosters wird
deshalb gebaut
hier sollen schon bald mehr als 3000
leyen untergebracht werden bislang
müssen die besucher nach den
meditationen oft noch lange strecken
zurück in ihre heimatstädte fahren und
immer mehr die ursprünglich wegen des
kleinen roboter münch gekommen sind
wollen gerne länger bleiben
das was ich hier höre seit ich das erste
mal da war hat meine seele wirklich ganz
tief gerührt
das wissen der mönche ist wie ein
riesiger see davon möchte ich mehr für
den nachwuchs ist also gesorgt und auch
schon soll bald in serie produziert
werden
der chinesische buddhismus scheint sich
seinen festen platz im land wieder zu
erobern hatte erfinder john fan angst
dass sein roboter mönch ihn und seine
kollegen ablesen könnte meinen sie
noch bin ich hier